il nous a quand même collé au plafond
c'est quand est arrivé avec les épaules
baudelaire c'était quand même la
révolution la plus totale alors là aussi
quand on ta mère et mesure 1 m 76 allées
les épaules étudie alors est ce que
c'est mais c'est ça non pas parce que
tout le monde était a dit non je crois
comment c'était avant toi c'était des
c'était la fin du baba quoi il y avait
eu le pain c'était ramollo ouais c'est
ça va pas à barrès étaient tous très
exotique folklore ça va j'ai commencé à
frapper qu'en valais 0,10 à vendre avant
de monter ma maison j'ai pris une
compagnie qui s'appelait café de paris
lyon on était en plein babar plein
folklore et moi je promotionner abord
paris la parisienne
le tailleur noir et ça ne s'était pas du
tout ça non ça a été ça cinq ans
les robes très moule et enfin bon les
talons hauts des terrains il retourne
dans la parisienne je l'avais pressenti
à réparer puis après j'ai monté ma
maison et puis ça a été les épaules
larges épaules larges c était le début
des 80 j'ai toujours quelques grossistes
alaoui suis toujours là j'ai commencé
dans la mode comme ça quand j'étais
danseur à l'opéra du rhin on m'a arrêté
dans la rue va pas tellement à
strasbourg je vis à paris pour arrêter
dans la rue pour lui demander où vous
pouvez trouver ce que je portais mais
c'est la danse qui m'a apporté ce parce
que la danse
savoir la présence ou pas la présence et
un appart physique et c'est aussi un
port de tête c'est aussi une tenue donc
la danse c'est ça c'est une construction
du corps c'est une architecture
et puis tout ça a fait son chemin si ça
voilà quoi toi qui as quand même
révolutionner les choses au début des 80
avec les épaules elle est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la ligne muller tout
simplement là maintenant j'ai
l'impression bomba que tu fais un peu
comme tous les autre sûr que tu fous il
ya un peu dans dans les autres modes
alors tu nous fais le psychédélique tu
nous fais la fri ohnona dans le
psychédélisme était le premier en
même temps c'est une remise en jeu c'est
une remise en cause des téléphones et ça
m'a coûté assez cher c'est une saison un
peu difficile s'est largement repris ma
toile largement donc je n'étais pas
trompé non mais ce que tu veux pas
l'impression après avoir été de l'avant
afin de proposer quelque chose de
réellement nouveau d'un seul coup de
revenir un peu en arrière parce que
finalement tu fais comme les autres
maintenant que tu fouilles à un peu dans
le passé pour trouver des trucs non tu
sais il ya eu une époque donc les années
80 ça a été une espèce de futurisme
c'est plus le cas maintenant et en
maintenant on est sur autre chose et moi
maintenant vont langage est ce que j'ai
envie de dire c'est le retour de la
science une sensualité l'instinct espèce
de joie dit du corps animal anti
moralité qu'on essaye de nouveau à
laquelle on essaie de nous faire croire
que jamais à la lutte et parce que je
vois je ne crois que ça explose de joie
ça
voilà donc c'est ça
soit parce que ça va se passer la
province tente quand tu fais un petit
galet 6 à bien voir avec le passé
mais je sais particulier de faire
maintenant il ya quatre ans parce que je
savais que ça allait venir et dans quoi
on était allé et qu'ils vont vivre des
années psychédéliques donc d'une
certaine façon très bien
fonctionné donc l'époque psychédélique
ce serait absolument génial chanteur
avec toi tu fais des films de pub si on
donne 300 mille francs tu fais un fils
de pub bah c'est pas une question 308
française question si le script est bien
imaginer que le bord soit bien et qu'on
me donne trois cent mille francs de fils
de oui à ce moment là s'il est très
bien les trois cent mille francs ça ce
n'est peut-être pas la compassion la
plus importante tu fais tu veux tu fais
des films ne vois tu t'intéresses à la
cinématographie à l'accuser de jaffa
fils un petit fils jean près partout
voilà tu fais des photos qui sont bien
des à ça maintenant vraiment sincèrement
je trouve que n'ont généralement ça a
rejoint les gens qui sont connus pour
quelque chose quand ils font autre chose
du bon ils font ça mais là franchement
c'était très bien des photos était et
est aussi étonnant que les derniers
faits dans la rade pas mal maintenant
tous les trucs toilettes mais alors est
ce que t'as pas peur que pendant que toi
tu fais tous ces trucs tes concurrents
qui font qu'une chose ils y arrivent
mieux que toi
ou tu la portance et
on a été actionnaire et aurier paris
doit pas obligatoirement raisonner comme
toi moi de penser que l'important c'est
que tu sois heureux ou alors si les
actionnaires en gueule je fais les
trouver sur le terrain les actionnaires
cela fait 40 contre 50 en un an d'accord
donc occuper mon livre de photos des cas
malgré les amigos anwar
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu